welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel studios just wrapped
their panel at d23 and i was there to
see it i just teleported like
nightcrawler back here to the blue
dungeon to break down all the big
announcements since nightcrawler really
goes through the brimstone dimension
when he teleports i actually saw some
pretty horrific things that i don't ever
want to talk about so let's break down
the news so the marvel section of the
panel began with an amazing performance
of the cast of rogerson musical from
hawkeye performing the captain america
theme song i can do this all day
and the performance was electric it was
such a great way to begin the panel but
let's move on and talk about the new
exclusive footage that was shown to the
attendees of d23 of black panther
wakanda forever this footage actually
showed queen ramonda talking to the u.n
we saw some of this in trailer footage
but this time we see some of the
delegates of the union including richard
ship toby ziegler from the west wing
playing the american delegate who was
snapping at queen raimondo about like
the security dilemma that they're now in
and then there was a french delegate who
was complaining about the use of
vibranium and weapons of mass
destruction specifically the fact that
vibranium cannot be picked up by metal
detectors which is very interesting i
feel like that's going to be like an
important plot point either in this
movie or in the future of the mcu but
ramonda snapped back at all them saying
look i understand where you're all
coming from that wakanda was the thing
you were always trying to get at she
said yes my king is dead and now you
think here's your chance to come at us
now this cross cuts with that footage
from the raid scene that we saw in the
trailer of those american we think
soldiers that were raiding uh what kind
of outreach center this is in mali and
it seems like they're trying to steal
their vibranium but then we realized
that some of the scientists and outreach
center are actually dormalate in
disguise and then they just wreck these
americans and it's awesome because this
u.n conference ends with raimondo
signalling durham alasha to bring in
these uh soldiers and basically she is
saying to the whole world anyone who
wants to come out wakanda the best of
luck and then we also see a bunch of
sizzle reel footage that it's just a
bunch of new shots including uh there
was definitely a new shot of atuma
rising up out of the water there was
footage of neymar swiping away some
blasts this movie just looks incredible
not just for the action and for the
production design but just the way ryan
coogler is editing this film now ryan
coogler stayed on stage afterwards to
introduce ironheart and we actually saw
some exclusive footage of the ironheart
series on disney plus which they are
currently in the middle production of
this includes jim rash returning as that
mit guy from civil war who's trying to
pitch his ideas to tony stark he's
basically yelling at rigory williams for
some of her mit engineering projects
like going way over budget he's like you
know you're not the only student at mit
and then something in her experiment
just kind of blows up in the lab we
learned for sure that anthony ramos is
definitely playing parker robins aka the
hood and a big theme of this part of the
panel is the fact that the hood
practices dark magic and to kevin feige
that was an interesting theme an
interesting distinction because it's
going to be a conflict between magic and
technology and we see some shots of
riggery williams new armored suits just
the whole look of the show and the way
the lighting works it just looks
distinctly different from so much of
what we've seen on disney plus okay on
to a very very important part of the
panel ant-man the watch quantum mania
now there's just a lot of like riffing
and goofing around for like the first
several minutes but they showed us some
new footage now most of this new footage
is pretty much what we saw at comic con
i made another video breaking down a
description of that footage but the big
difference here is that the final shot
of the trailer goes further so we get
more of this back and forth between kang
and ant-man and after kang asks you're
an avenger huh didn't i kill you before
they keep going and kang says well all
the avengers die eventually and then he
tells scott lang that something was
stolen from him and that only ant-man
can help steal it back so now we learn
exactly why ant-man needs to be part of
this kang story it's that ant-man is
basically the mcu's cleverest thief it's
gonna be another heist plot it brings up
this question of what was stolen from
kang maybe we should be asking who was
stolen from kang my theory is that the
thing that was stolen from him is ravono
renslayer who we know is his love and
seemed to be someone kept under the
specific variant of he who remains
domain in the tva maybe kang needs
ant-man to help him steal back ramona
rinslayer it's really a kidnapping plot
okay one of the most exciting parts of
the panel was the announcements for
werewolf by night this is directed by
composer michael g aquino you can see
the trailer for this online it looks
incredible it's going to be a one-off
halloween special streaming on disney
plus on october 7th it's cut together
like this cheesy halloween special in
the style of the director ed wood or
vincent price's halloween specials where
a bunch of people are locked in like an
old haunted house and one of them is
revealed to be a werewolf and they have
to suss out which of them is werewolf
which is really great it's like andrew
garfield's favorite game werewolf but of
course kyle garcia bernard is playing
jacob russell or jack russell the one
who is the werewolf the whole look of
the show with it's like glitchy editing
with its black and white imagery it's
just gonna be an amazing thing that i
can't wait to break down laura donnelly
from the nevers is also gonna play a
role in this story okay then they
brought out don cheadle to talk about
secret invasion and you can also see a
trailer for secret invasion online right
now that trailer that's on youtube is
basically what was shown at comic-con
but the footage that we saw in d23
included this whole opening scene
between roadie and fury they're sitting
in a restaurant together and brodie has
the security detail that fury's like how
well do you know your security detail
and roadie's like hey now's not a time
to be playing games with like titles you
i'm the only friend you have left fury
and then fury says we are under an
invasion right now and brody's like oh i
know he said 15 years ago the pentagon
brought me in on a secret project
because they had been aware of the
scroll invasion this whole time so
fueling some fire to our theories that
fury might actually have been a scroll
this whole time in the mcu there might
actually be a meta angle there that's
why you know there was a recast between
terence howard and don cheadle but yeah
this trailer footage looks incredible
ben mendelsohn in this situation where a
bunch of like look-alikes all kind of
surround him we see olivia coleman's
character we think it's going to be a
modern version of union jack who might
be union jack's like granddaughter or
great-granddaughter from the first
captain america film have like a british
version of nick fury we didn't get a
release date for a secret innovation yet
it's gonna be sometime spring 2023. okay
we also got some exciting announcements
for loki season two including that the
cast is going to include newcomer kehue
kwan aka short round from temple of doom
dated from goonies and just recently
blew all of our minds and everything
everywhere all at once this show is
currently in production quan is going to
be playing it looks like a an archivist
or a record keeper for the tva the
trailer footage opens with like loki in
a creepy empty tva headquarters and he's
kind of like glitching around as if
someone is screwing with him with like
uh one of those three set devices at one
point he chiseled away a wall mural of
the timekeepers and behind it are three
giant gold faces of jonathan majors as
either the variant he remains or one of
the kang variants i cannot wait for the
second season i think it's gonna be so
so so so good especially to see what
versions of jonathan major's kang we see
in it thanks to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video fall has fallen
into our laps and that means one thing
it's time for fall food and before you
start shoveling spoonfuls of pumpkin
spice mix into your mouth let me remind
you that there is a better way to enjoy
all the tastes that paul has to offer
and hellofresh is here to help
hellofresh now has 30 dinner recipes to
choose from every week that's the most
choices for any meal kid and beyond that
every hellofresh recipe includes ripe
just picked produce that travels from
the farm to your door in less than a
week it's a cornucopia of fall flavors
just in time for cornucopia season which
for the record is fall i love how easy
it is to make these recipes fool-proof
step-by-step recipes make cooking simple
fun and a great way to make your house
smell like fall out of smell like nutmeg
plus hellofresh cuts back on the time
spent in the kitchen with meals ready in
around 30 minutes or less it's also a
great value even at full price its
pre-proportioned ingredients mean you
don't waste money on excess food hello
fresh is up to 72 percent cheaper than
dining at a restaurant or even grocery
shopping that way you can scroll some
money away for your life-size scale
captain america statue of liberty
halloween costume i got to cook in a
meal last night it was so savory i felt
like a grown-up i still taste the yummy
savory garlic flavors on my tongue
so go to hellofresh.com and use the code
rockstars 16 for up to 16 free meals
across seven boxes and three surprise
gifts use the code rockstars 16 for up
to 16 free meals across seven boxes and
three surprise gifts then we got a whole
panel for echo with the lock or [ __ ]
playing maya lopez who saw ed hawkeye
this footage focused mostly on the
character maya lopez and her indigenous
history like what the name echo really
really means to her and how her heritage
is echoing through the generations this
all looks beautiful the big reveal
though is of course that wilson fisk is
still alive we see him in the trailer
with his eye bandaged over we also see
maya lopez battling with the other track
suits now kind of a brief and slightly
disappointing announcement kevin feige
did confirm that matt shackman is
directing the fantastic four movie which
is great news unfortunately he didn't
make any announcements about who is
playing the members of the fantastic
four or give us any other details about
that which is kind of like dude come on
but anyway vincent d'onofrio stayed on
stage after the echo panel because he's
like uh aren't you gonna talk about my
show and then we hear the voice of
charlie cox saying uh don't you mean my
show so yeah we're talking about
daredevil born again now and they didn't
have any footage to show because they
haven't begun production yet they're
gonna do that next year but charlie cox
did talk kevin feige and just showing a
clip of daredevil in an upcoming episode
of she hold probably a few weeks from
now and this scene is awesome and it is
super horny so jen walters in under
human form is beside daredevil with his
like golden mask they're on a rooftop
listening in on some goons or is it
henchmen because they have this little
funny debate about what's the difference
between a henchman and a goon and
daredevil who clearly is an experienced
daredevil in this world of superhero
dumb vigilantism says that a henchman
does what he does because he really
believes in the cause whereas a goon
just does what he does for the paycheck
and then matt murdock listens to all the
heartbeats he's able to count how many
goons are downstairs and jen is like how
are you able to do that and he's like
i'm counting their heartbeats and then
she's skeptical so he listens to her
heartbeat and it gets really really sexy
and they almost kiss but then she like
shakes herself out of it and then he
flips down below and says let me handle
this so yeah super excited for that
episode of shield okay next we got the
cast of captain america new world order
that includes of course anthony mackie
playing sam wilson captain america danny
ramirez coming back as joaquin torres is
soon gonna be the new falcon carl
lundley is coming back as isaiah bradley
and though she wasn't on the panel shira
haas is gonna be playing israeli
superheroine sabra but the big headline
here is that tim blake nelson is coming
back as samuel stern's the leader
they're bringing back everyone from that
2008 hulk film apparently we last saw
him when that uh serum was dripping into
the open wound in his forehead and his
head started to grow so yeah it's
looking more confirmed that the
intelligentsia is going to play a very
important role in captain america new
world order and it will probably be set
up in she-hulk by the end of it i think
they're the ones who are behind the
wrecking crew i don't know if tim blake
nelson himself will cameo in she-hulk
but the fact that they announced now
seems like that was something that was
done ahead of the finale of shield now
what will the plot be of new world order
well new world order again was the title
the first episode of the fact in the
winter soldier and that episode dealt
with the whole idea of like conspiracy
theories remember walking tourists
thought that cap was living on the moon
there's a lot of fake news out there and
that's going to be the new political
fight that captain america has to fight
in the modern age is a fight against
misinformation okay then we finally
learn the lineup of the thunderbolts
gonna include julia louis dreyfus coming
back as val david harper coming back as
red guardian alexis schuster hannah john
cayman as ghost from ant-man the wasp
why russell as john walker from the fact
of the winter soldier olgaenko is going
back as task master from black widow
florence pugh is playing elena bulova
and sebastian stan is leading the group
as james buchanan barnes bucky so
basically many of our theories have
proven cracked minus abomination and the
marvel section of the d23 panel ends
with the marbles the full cast the
marbles out here and i gotta say this
trailer for the marvels with nina
costa's direction was my favorite piece
of marvel footage that i saw all weekend
i was completely surprised and blown
away because i just didn't really know
what to expect about this movie and it
just looks incredible it's cut to the
beastie boys intergalactic perfect song
choice we learn exactly where kamala
khan went when she traded places with
carol danvers it turns out she didn't
swap places with carol danvers all three
of them are swapping places so the
trailer opens with monica rambo as an
astronaut floating outside the saber
space station with nick fury on it
that's probably where he's been in space
maybe that's the scroll space station it
kind of looks like a version of the peak
to be honest monica inner space suit
floats toward this glowing blue energy
field and the moment she touches it that
is when she swaps places and now it's
kamala khan freaking out inside the
space dude she taps on the window and
waves at nick fury and asks if she can
be part of the avengers super funny we
learned where monica went monica swapped
places with wherever carol was it looks
like monica crashes on this moon with a
bunch of cree warriors and of course we
know where carol went she went into the
bedroom of the khan family and we see
monica rambo and carol danvers meeting
the cons it's all very adorable and the
way the three of these women work
together it's just so cool to see how
they work together we see a bit of
stretchy action coming from kamala one
point kamala meets the flirkin goose as
goose devours someone and kamala freaks
out scared zomway ashton is playing a
mysterious villain who carries a
hammer-headed staff i have so many
questions about this and i just can't
wait till everyone can see the trailer
so that we can break it down properly
but other than that a bit of a bummer no
announcements about the fantastic
forecasting about the x-men they didn't
really fill in those titles that were
left blank on the phase six calendar
which just leaves us more time for
speculation oh well so which of these
announcements are you most excited for
follow me on tick tock instagram and
twitter hey boss subscribe to new
rockstars for breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you